what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data if
you're new here my name is richard and
this is the channel where we talk about
all things data data science statistics
and programming subscribe for all kinds
of content just like this and hit the
notification Bell so YouTube notifies
you whenever I upload a video so I did a
video a little while ago comparing R and
Python in the year 2020 and I concluded
that while Python is relatively speaking
anyway the king of the TOB index and of
data science jobs in 2020 R is still
very much alive and well while Python
has been getting more popular and faster
R is still a fundamental part of a lot
of different companies analytics
infrastructures and things like that
just simply you don't change overnight
that and when you take a lot of
different data science and analytics
functionalities R is still competitive
with or just downright better than
python is but a lot of people ask when
they start picking up a new language do
I have to memorize this many functions
the short answer is sort of so most
people know that R is open source and it
comes with a ton of different packages
that you can install and then load there
are a few packages which you really
should know all of the capabilities of
because if you don't you really end up
selling yourself short and it can take
you way too long to work through some
problems that exist in the real world
just because you may try and create your
own solution from scratch not knowing
that the solution to that kind of
problem already exists in some package
that's out there but it's not a true
exercise in memory because a lot of our
packages will come with their own cheat
sheets and it's a surprisingly low
number of packages which will cover most
of the functionalities that a lot of
data scientists will have to do from day
to day so I thought it might be helpful
to run through ten of the packages which
are going to serve a lot of people the
best keep in mind this is not a
comprehensive list and I'm mostly going
for general usability over
specialization so just as an example if
you're doing a time series analysis
you'll probably at least
want to look at the zoo package but I'm
not including that on here because time
series is a fairly specific sort of
application but if you know all ten of
these packages
it'll truly be easy to handle a lot of
the problems that real-world data will
throw at you and it'll also be easy to
pick up new packages and add them to
your workflow as needed now these are
generally in no particular order but
these first five packages are part of
the core tidy verse that means it's
super simple just to run installed on
packages tidy verse followed by library
tidy verse and you are ready to rock and
roll with these packages first and
foremost is deep liar now this is going
to be your go-to for most of your data
wrangling and data manipulation needs
now one of the things that makes the
pliers super nice is that it operates
with the pipe function now this thing
looks pretty weird at first but it's
actually awesome and I think of it like
a venn statement in English basically
you're saying take your data then select
these columns then filter these rows
just as an example this is the first
page of the deep liar cheat sheet and
now notice there's a lot of different
functions and applier but there's only a
few absolute core functionalities so if
we start on the right side you've got
the Select function which you can use to
select your variables
aka your features for your data set then
if we move into the center you've got
filter which you can use to subset rows
based on a condition that you specify
distinct is another self-explanatory
function that I use a little bit still
if we look in the center towards the
bottom you've got a range which is the
equivalent of like a sequel order by
statement then on the right again you've
got mutate which creates variables based
on other variables and there's other
extensions of that such as mutate all
and mutate at but then once we end on
the left hand side we've got group by
and summarized now these are very quick
easy
and convenient ways to create detailed
summaries or even to create summary
stats and then do more wrangling on the
new data set that you've created now
once you've got your data all wrangled
into a form that you can at least
somewhat work with number two on the
list is going to be ggplot2 and this is
going to be your go-to for most things
in the data visualization Department I
really love this package because it's
incredibly flexible and that's because
ggplot2 operates through what's called
the grammar of graphics framework and
this basically means that any sort of
graph can be comprised of at least three
separate parts but above all else you
need
number one data number two a coordinate
mapping system and number three objects
or as ggplot2 likes to call them gee
ohms this is just the first of two pages
of the ggplot2 cheat sheet and most of
what's going on here is just the
different types of visualizations that
you can create and the possibilities are
endless so you've got density plots
histograms bar charts scatter plots line
plots rectangles pretty much whatever
you need now if you're not used to the
grammar of graphics framework there can
definitely be a bit of a learning curve
and that's why the example in the bottom
left is super helpful just to walk
through this example it's saying make a
plot of the MGP data set and then under
the AES argument
there's the variable highway going to
the x-axis and the variable city going
to the y-axis the giome point add-on
tells the function to add points to the
graph so we're basically creating a
scatter plot the color equals cyl
argument to it tells ggplot to color the
points based on values of the cyl
variable next we've got giome smooth
which adds a smooth line that is
basically a least squares line there the
chord Cartesian and scale color gradient
parts which are maybe a little bit
redundant because you're basically just
specifying the coordinate system and the
color scale but then there's also the
theme underscore BW object
which imposes a theme on your ggplot2
graph for design purposes then after all
that work here's our graph simple
straightforward enough you've got the
highway variable on the x-axis the city
variable on the y-axis and the points
are colored based on the cyl variable so
you've just got a scatterplot with a
line of best fit through it
nothing to it now number three on our
list is tidy are now tidy are exists for
exactly one purpose and that's to get
your data into a tidy format this
basically means that every row is an
observation every column is a variable
and every cell in your data has a value
in it now tidy R is actually the next
iteration of packages like reshape and
reshape - except it's a little bit more
stripped down and actually has less
functionality there's really four core
functions that I use consistently with
tidy are starting on the right side
you've got separate and unite now these
can be used for breaking a variable down
into multiple variables or turning
multiple variables into one respectively
but then you've got gather and spread in
the middle these have actually been
replaced with the newer functions pivot
wider and pivot longer but the idea is
you can condense multiple different
variables into new rows or vice versa
so if you look at the example under
gather you've got 1999 and 2000 as
different columns but this function
makes it easy to turn those into just
one variable which is and just call that
thing year this can work wonders for
getting your data nice and clean and
tidy now that your data is hopefully in
a nice and clean and tidy format it's
probably time to pass different
functions to it and this brings us to
number four which is / is it / or / are
either way it's named after the weird
vibrating sound that cats make so it
immediately gets points in my book for
that / gives you ways to deal with lists
and also to map functions to the
different elements of a vector or to a
list now this is sort of like what you
would
with a for-loop except it's much easier
to read and much faster here's the per
our cheat sheet so on the left hand side
we've got map functions so we can
execute a function multiple times to
different elements of a list or to a
vector now the different functions can
return lists data frames string factors
numeric vectors whatever you want it's
very similar to the L apply function and
general apply family of functions in
base R but then you've got a ton of
super useful functionalities for
wrangling with your data when you've got
lists you've got different
functionalities for filtering values
creating summaries restructuring the
data all kinds of great stuff number
five on the list is gonna be string are
and stringer is gonna be your go-to for
your string and your text and your
regular expression needs now stringer
does have a lot of functionalities that
also exist in base R but there are a lot
more user-friendly and just frankly
easier to remember in string R than they
are in base R so string R is fairly
straightforward because most all of its
functions begin with the prefix STR but
you've got a fairly comprehensive
toolkit here you can detect patterns you
can create sub strings and easily turn
those into new features you've got tools
for replacing patterns and predefined
substrings this whole package will be at
its most useful when you have a data
frame that's in tidy form where several
of your features are of character tied
number six on this list is the first one
that's not going to be part of the court
ID verse and that's gonna be [ __ ] date
and [ __ ] date on top of having an
overall awesome name is gonna be your
go-to for dealing with your problems
involving date or date time
aka POSIX C T variables let's face it
date times an R can be a giant pain to
deal with sometimes and they can have a
bit of a learning curve with them when
you work with them with [ __ ] date it's
usually a breeze right up front you've
got the as date/time function which is
basically a wrapper for turning what
looks like a date/time into a character
string and then into a POSIX seat
which is the main date time class that
you work with in our but then your core
functions are in the middle here with
extracting things like the date the year
the month parts etc very helpful stuff
and naturally you can both extract and
manipulate your data using these
functions and there's also a ton of
other functions on the second page for
adding increments of time as well as
handling durations super handy package
[ __ ] date is definitely one to have in
your repertoire number seven on this
list is a package which is transparent
and reflects light and I'm talking of
course about shiny shiny is one of the
most powerful and overall awesome
packages in the entire our ecosystem
what it is is it's a tool for creating
interactive web applications that end
users can play with and in my opinion
anyway it truly blows anything that you
can do in Python out of the water let's
start on the left hand side here a shiny
app will consist of two distinct
components a UI and a server you can
build them in the same file but I like
organizing myself by keeping them
separate now the UI is your front-end or
a web page which will have inputs which
are configured by the end user then the
server is your back-end so basically
your computer that's running a live our
session on the right side of this cheat
sheet you've got some examples of the
different inputs the end user can play
with those in the UI and those inputs
get fed to different output objects
inside of your server some examples our
action buttons are checkboxes which can
be used to configure various things but
then also dates files numbers text
inputs you name it then if you look down
the middle those outputs could be data
tables regular tables text strings plots
other UIs which is a super powerful
feature in and of itself and it takes a
long time I think to get the handle of
shiny and of reactive elements in
general but it's truly a remarkable
framework and the power of it will amaze
you and probably your client
to number eight is our markdown and with
this you're getting the functionalities
of a ton of different packages all with
the end goal of creating usable easy to
read documents and notebooks or markdown
is incredible and I really think the
integration that it has with the our
Studio IDE makes it easier to use and
more powerful than Jupiter notebooks and
trust me I have nothing but love for
Jupiter notebooks here's the first page
of an r markdown cheat sheet and the
long and the short of our markdown is it
takes a lot of HTML and CSS and stuff
that data scientists typically don't
know very well I know I certainly don't
and just doing all that for you so you
can quickly and easily create reports
and this page of the cheat sheet
basically walks you through a lot of the
steps and syntax for creating an R
markdown file you've got a step for
creating a document which you can then
knit to turn into a doc or a PDF your R
code is gonna come inside various code
chunks and this is a super helpful tool
for your workflow if you have to code
but also constantly share your results
with others because it just keeps
everything in one place plus there's
also features for incorporating shiny
input into the R markdown as well so you
can create interactive documents moving
on to number nine we've got carat now
carat and shiny basically compete day to
day for the distinction of my favorite
our package of all time which one of
these two I like more sort of depends on
what mood I'm in more than anything
carat is a front to back tool for all of
your machine learning needs now I will
point out there's another package called
tidy models which compiles a bunch of
smaller machine learning packages into a
tidy framework but in the year 2020 I do
think carat is still a bit more mature
future development is probably going
into tidy models rather than carat but
the same guy max Khan works on both of
them and in the year 2020 I have to say
I do still prefer carat here's your
carat cheat sheet now let's actually
start down the middle column so carat
makes
processing your data for all of your
machine learning needs super easy you
can even start by partitioning your data
into test and training sets which isn't
listed here but you've got normalizing
your predictors transforming them
filtering imputing missing data what
have you then you can select how your
model gets trained and summarized using
the train control function starting with
your resampling options you can pick
between your usual cross-validation
bootstrap out-of-bag resampling etc now
you can also do sub sampling methods
like up sampling or down sampling in
those times where you're working in
classification problems where you have
imbalanced classes you have summary
functions like the two class summary for
an ROC curve PR summary for precision
recall info etc then last but not least
you have the Train function so you pick
the machine learning method you want and
believe me you have tons of options here
you can pick how many values per tuning
parameter you want the method to
evaluate and then BAM
you've got yourself a very easily
trained machine learning model that you
can then use for prediction purposes
last but not least we've got reticulate
and i'm putting this one on the list
because I'm a firm believer in treating
the two languages as are and Python
rather than our vs. Python there's no
need to treat it as a competition all
the time because these two languages
really do have the ability to complement
one another very nicely also let's just
be real writing Python code from the our
studio IDE is just awesome so my
favorite way to do this is to write the
Python code from inside an armed
markdown document then it's super simple
inside the code chunk you specify R or
Python then you're ready to rock and
roll you can import the Python modules
that you want and use your usual dollar
sign operator to extract the attributes
the way you typically would in a Python
workflow but then you've got super
convenient and easy mapping between our
objects and Python objects you can do
this manually too but reticulate gives
you the awesome PI to our
and our 2pi functions so these are 10
packages in our which I really recommend
any data scientist to learn and I hope
you do realize that while there's a lot
to learn in the data science world
there's a little bit of a Pareto
principle at work here with our packages
I listed off way less than 20% of all of
the packages in the our ecosystem but
still if you master these packages
you're going to be able to do a huge
number of things that you would need to
do in the data science universe and yes
there will always be a learning curve
but me personally I find learning 10
things a lot more manageable than
learning fifty or a hundred things so
thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it and you'd like to support my
work the most helpful thing you could do
for me would be to share this video
otherwise please consider at least
smashing the like button and then I'll
see you all in the not so distant future
until then Richard on data